[Music]
in the world of gaming journals there is
no such thing as coincidence everything
happens for a reason every single line
between the characters is there for a
reason
often foreshadowing main events far in
advance in the world where everything
has the meaning Cassell names are no
different names are not just names after
a bit of research you notice that in all
cases those names mean and symbolize
something in this video we are going to
research the origin and the true meaning
behind the name the ancestral home of
House Stark
Winterfell is a just a made-up name by
its founder bran the Builder who beside
Winterfell also built the wall after the
long night ended 8,000 years ago or is
it just like the wall and all the
castles Sylvester is supposed to mean
and symbolize something most castles of
Westeros have been named after its
location after its founder and even that
there are successful Allegiance although
there are a few castles which name
origins are explained by legend the most
popular castles named after its founder
are Casterly Rock and Harrenhal
Harrenhal a huge castle the largest one
in all of Westeros occupying three times
as much land area as Winterfell although
it's the most still home and is named
after its founder the castle was built
over 300 years ago by house [ __ ] their
only house of the Iron Islands which had
overrun and conquered the Riverlands it
took three generations to construct King
harren the black completed castle and he
arrogantly named it here hall after
himself on the very same day that last
break was late however Aegon Targaryen
and his sisters landed with their army
from Dragonstone in the mouth of the
Blackwater River along with their tweet
reagan's beginning the war of conquest
hiren thought the walls of his massive
castle could withstand any assault but
he did not realize that dragons could
simply fly over them in the burning of
Harrenhal Aegon used his dragon balerion
to roast King harren and all his sons
alive within their own Tower
Harrenhal was blasted with dragon fire
and left half ruined the name of the
ancestral stronghold of House Lannister
Casterly Rock is also coming from its
founder Casserly but also from its rock
formation Rock making it Casterly Rock
The Rock was measured at three times the
height of the wall or the high tower of
whole town and although I was not too
happy with its appearance that you got
to finally seen since seven I'm still
glad that it's so at least
Casterly Rock is named for the family
that ruled it in age of Heroes the guess
release who no longer exists
the Lannisters traced the rule over it
back to land clever could wreck the cast
early start of their Castle and claimed
it for his own now let's take a look on
the castles that took the name mirror of
its location or because of its location
River and the ancestral house of house
Tully is situated in investor
at the confluence of the tumblestone and
redfork rivers riverine is a strong
three-sided castle although not
especially large the castle is bordered
on the north by the tumblestone River
and on the south by the red Fork River
while on the west the third side faces a
massive man-made ditch it's easy to see
why named River ran for this castle
another castle named due to its location
is Dragonstone the ancestral seat of
House Targaryen was literally named
after its location Dragonstone is a
castle located on the island of the same
name at the interests of the Blackwater
Bay located below dragon mountain shaped
from stone to look like dragons dragon
stone was the original seat of House
Targaryen in Westeros and had been
colonized and fortified at the
westernmost outpost of the Valyrian
freehold the castle was built by the
Targaryen some five hundred years ago
and they settled Island Dragonstone as a
trading outpost of the great Valyrian
freehold the island dragon stone has a
small port in the large castle on it
that took the name after the island it's
located on Dragonstone just like castle
dragon stone castle pike also - the name
of the island it's located on pike is a
stronghold and seat of house Greyjoy
located on the island pike which is one
of the seven major Iron Islands Castle
pike is an ancient stronghold and the
cliff it was built on has been eroded by
sea living the tower standing on stone
stacks by the soul that its original
builders and Lords are unknown
according to main search people living
on the island Pike say it was always
called Pike and the castle is named
after the island so the stronghold of
house Greyjoy just like the stronghold
of House Targaryen is named after the
island it's located on
although the graters themselves claimed
that eats other way around the next two
castles meant little to no explanation
the twins known as the Crossing is the
Sato house Frey in the northern
Riverlands it consists of two new
identical towers in the fortified bridge
over the green Fork of the river trident
the Freys have held the crossing of the
green fork for six hundred years
beginning when a petty Lord built a
rickety wooden bridge over the nearest
portion of the river it of the family
three generations to complete the bridge
in stone at ravage they built timber
capes on each bank of the river
since then the phrase have grown wealthy
by charging a heavy toll on all those
who needed to cross the timber capes
have since been replaced by stone these
castles are what gives a stronghold its
name the twins for they are identical we
also have castles across the Westeros
that was named after successful
allegiances such as the stronghold of
house Martell Sunspear in the events of
game eternal suno the Martell says
ruling princes of Dorne and Lords of
Sunspear either house being the ruling
house of Dorne
but they were not always that powerful
throughout the history house Martell
not always one of the Great Houses of
the Seven Kingdoms there were times when
the Martell's were just minor Dornish
Lords the same shape which is now part
of Sunspear used to be an ancient cape
of house Martell Minor Dornish Lords
this changed when rhoynish warrior queen
Nymeria arrived in the one metre 10,000
ships around 700 AC Lord Mortimer tell
the Lord of the sand ship with her and
this alliance of the Martell's with the
Rhoyne are led to the unification of
Dorne in the Mira's war to symbolize
their union the original golden spear
sigil Oh more smart Ella's combined with
the red Sun schedule of Lemuria creating
the red sand piers bell golden spear
sigil that house Martell has used this
as a jewel ever since it's not the only
thing that symbolizes their union the
state of the ruling princes and
princesses of Dorne became Sunspear the
new castle which developed around the
sand ship Sunspear was named after the
union of the Martell spear with the son
of the Rhoyne er then we also have a
castles which name origins or legends
such as the origin of storms and the
ancestral sitacles Baratheon a
formidable fortress located on the
southeastern coast of Westeros so we're
looking shipbreaker bay one of the
strongest castles in the realm storm's
end was one the ancestral seat of storm
Kings of house reyne then extending back
many thousands of years legend claims
that it was built by the rain gods
grieved the first strong King during the
dawn age very clear the war against the
sea god and goddess of the wind after
they kill his family and guests ruining
his wedding through their daughter it
was said that the rain raised six
castles each larger and more formidable
than last but all were destroyed by
storms the mast is seven Castle was
named storms then because it was able to
injure the storms some believe this was
because the children of the forest took
the hand in its construction using their
magic in raising the castle walls which
allows it to resist the storms others
believe that the young boy who grew up
to be brained a pillar advised the rain
on his construction storms then became
the seat of the rulers to the Stormlands
the storm Kings for millennia until the
Targaryen scheme when Aegon the
Conqueror invaded Westeros he sent his
commander and rumored half-brother or
spur Theon to take storms and the last
of the storm Kings led the safety of his
stronghold and met Baratheon in open
battle he was defeated and orys
baratheon to the last from kings from
house during dawn domains
sigil motto and order becoming the
father of house Baratheon storms and is
said to be protected by spells woven
into its variables that prevent magic
for penetrate needs defenses or passing
through it which is why I'm looking for
its appearance in the final season and
it might even be the best Castle for the
living to face the night King from we
so here's some castle names such as
Eyrie or interval whose name origins
meanings are not officially known as it
was not named after its founder or its
location or some successful agents but
if you read all the history of Westeros
all the events that occurred there you
could come to the origin of it which is
the case from interval about which I'm
going to talk in a minute to understand
the origin of the name of an ancient
castle and see to how serene Eyrie you
need to take a look on the Middle Ages
dictionary area is the word that means
so large nest of an eagle or other bird
of prey built keine tree or in a cliff
area also means a high or inaccessible
place from which someone can observe
what's below them let me remind you the
disturb is from the Middle Ages and it
fits the historical year Martin was
trying to evoke since cows are in
schedule is a falcon this means that
their stronghold the Eyrie which is
situated in the mountains of the Moon is
try the peak known as the Giants lands
several thousand feet above the valley
below is essentially their nest let's
recap the castle names we had thus far
we have castles named after its founder
such as Casterly Rock and Harrenhal
we have castles that took the name
either of its location or because of its
location such as Dragonstone River on
pike in the twins castles have also been
named that they're successful agencies
such as the stronghold of house Martell
Sunspear we have castles which name
origins are not officially known but can
be explained with a bit of research such
as the origin of the name Eyrie
we also have castle names such origins
are legends such as the one of storms
end most emergence of the popular
castles have been officially explained
but not Winterfell
Winterfell is not named after its
founder or its location or some
successful agents
there's not even a legend explaining why
name interval for House Stark stronghold
but there's a theory and the theory of
interval is just like Starfall built and
named after the major event that
happened on that very same place starpha
is a castle in Dorne in the ancestral
seat of house Dayne according to legend
star foals built her the first day and
found a magic stone after he followed
the path of a shooting star star fall is
so called because a meteor referred to
as a fallen star which fell out of the
sky nearby almost 2,000 years ago
the Danes forged the sword out of the
meteorite or called dawn long story
short star fall is a castle raised and
named after star that fell at that place
it's basically named after the major
event that happened there and I believe
is the similar case with the Winterfell
as well star might not have fallen where
Winterfell stands but winter might have
does the name Winterfell eight thousand
years before the Targaryen conquests the
winter known as the long night descended
upon the world unless didn't
generation in the midst of this darkness
the White Walkers emerge from an
uttermost north of Westeros the polar
regions of the lands of always winter
they wilted razor thin sorts of ice and
race fights to fight the living the
children forests and I realized the
first men fought valiantly against them
but were driven southwards by their
advance eventually the first men and the
children of forests formed an alliance
and rallied to defend themselves in a
struggle known as the war for the dawn
while workers were defeated and driven
back into the uttermost North steps were
taken to ensure that the people would
never be caught off guard by an invasion
from the north again brand build a
raised wall an imposing structure of
solid ice and magic
stretching 100 leagues from the west to
east cutting up the lands of always
winter from the remainder of Westeros
the wall a massive fortification
standing 700 feet tall and stretching
from one side of the continent to the
other was constructed along the northern
moon states most of northern Westeros to
bar the Walkers return although it
failed the task it had its purpose
meaning and symbolism we know the brand
builder built both the wall in
Winterfell after the long night past and
so it's impossible that just bran built
a wall to protect the realm from the
future advance of the night king he also
built the castle very Winterfell and
served the long night is to come again
the living would nowhere to face it at a
place where Winterfell before Winterfell
bran the Builder even made sure for
people to know that winter will
eventually come again with phony health
stark and giving in the Moto words
winter is coming the origin and the true
meaning behind our state Winterfell
could and in this series the Placer
winter was defeated where Winterfell and
as always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]